hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live zuerst in Australien dann auf der
ganzen Welt war heute internationaler
klimastreik hier Bilder eben aus
Australien aber auch in Italien und auch
bei uns hier in Deutschland auf der
ganzen Welt sind Menschen vereint im
Streik für den Klimaschutz auf die
Straße gegangen sie fordern weniger
CO2-Emissionen Einhaltung der Pariser
Klimaziele und vor allem eine
Verkehrswende Fridays for future hatte
dazu aufgerufen eine der größten Demos
von in Berlin statt wie wir sehen können
gerade die Aktivisten Aktivisten fordern
einen Stopp für den Ausbau von
Autobahnen weniger Autos mehr ÖPNV so
die Forderung
das sieht Bundesverkehrsminister
Wissingen ganz anders er hat heute eine
Studie vorgelegt wonach seiner Meinung
nach genau das Gegenteil jetzt das
richtige wäre wir hören kurz rein bleibt
dominierendes Verkehrsmittel im
güterbereich die Verkehrsleistungen im
Güterverkehr wird bis
2051 um insgesamt 46% zunehmen den mit
Abstand größten Zuwachs
gibt es auf der Straße dort werden wir
eine Steigerung von 54% haben wir
brauchen aber das ist als ein Fazit auch
den beschleunigten Ausbau der Straße
wenn wir unseren Wohlstand sichern
wollen
deshalb heute unser Thema Autobahnbau
ihr seht hier hinten Bremsen oder
Beschleunigen ihr könnt Fragen dazu
stellen mitdiskutieren gerne bei uns im
Stream oder per Mail seid einfach mit
dabei denn wir können mit spannenden
Menschen darüber diskutieren jetzt bei
uns die klimaaktivistin Annika Rittmann
von Fridays for future und außerdem der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
FDP-Fraktion Lukas Köhler hallo schön
dass sie beide bei uns zu Gast sind
sehr schön das war ganz gleichzeitig
sprechen wir darüber was heute passiert
ist und natürlich über das große Ganze
also Autobahnausbau stoppen versus jetzt
ganz schnell mehr Autobahn komplett
gegen gesetzlich diese beiden Positionen
die Schlüssel die der Verkehrsminister
Wissing also aus der Studie zieht sind
das ihrer Meinung nach die ganz falschen
Frau Rittmann
naja die Frage ist am Ende ja wie halten
wir das Pariser Klimaabkommen ein und
wie halten die Bundesregierung auch ihre
eigenen Ziele ein und da ist ganz klar
es müssen weniger Autos auf den Straßen
sein und wenn man sich jetzt gerade in
ÖPNV anschaut dann ist natürlich klar
dass die Prognose ist es werden mehr
Menschen das Auto nutzen weil kein
Mensch hat Bock morgen um 6 Uhr
aufzustehen und dann auf einem Bus zu
warten der nicht kommt aber dann muss
man noch das System ändern anstatt im
jetzigen System zu sagen boah es werden
mehr Autos
und wenn ich jetzt bei Ihnen direkt
meine Gegenfrage stellen darf Herr
Köhler also der Autobahnausbau so klingt
das ja der ist Ihnen bei der FDP ein
bisschen wichtiger als der Klimaschutz
oder
ganz im Gegenteil ich glaube die die
Studie die Volker wir sind heute
vorgelegt hat zeigt ja dass wir
insbesondere im Transportwesen mehr LKWs
bekommen und wir brauchen auch mehr LKWs
wenn wir uns zum Beispiel die Ziele bei
den Erneuerbaren anschauen es müssen ja
auch windradflügel über Autobahnen und
über Straßen transportiert werden und es
gibt keine Bahnstrecken die zu jedem
Feld zu jeder Wiese zu jedem Waldstück
in der wir eine z.B Windkraftanlage
bauen wollen führen wird und deswegen
ist doch ganz klar dass wir Autobahn
bauen ich glaube auch nicht dass die
Frage ist wie viele Autos oder wie viele
LKWs rumfahren sondern die Frage ist
womit werden sie betrieben werden sie
mit ähm wie fühlst mit Erneuerbaren
Kraftstoffen und mit Strom also mit
Batterien betrieben oder mit Wasserstoff
ist es für den Klimawandel völlig egal
werden sie weiterhin Öl betrieben ist
das aber ein Problem und deswegen freue
ich mich auch dass wir heute im
Bundestag schon mal die erste den ersten
Schritt Richtung mehr synthetische
Kraftstoffe beschlossen haben klar aber
auch wir müssen in der Infrastruktur zum
Beispiel bei Ladesäulen bei lade
Infrastruktur bei der E-Mobilität
schneller
über diese umstrittene Diskussion mit
den e-fuels darüber werden wir später
noch sprechen dass er an dieser Stelle
gesagt aber erstmal wollen wir in einen
Beitrag schauen denn es war ja heute
dann doch ganz klar also der
Verkehrsminister hat sich positioniert
dem Verkehrsministerium ihrer Partei der
FDP Herr Köhler der ist vor allem eins
im Moment wichtig der beschleunigte
Ausbau der Autobahnen und wir schauen
mal einen Beitrag diskutieren danach
zusammen ein Beitrag von Thomas
als die Ampel begann da war sie sich
schnell einig Großprojekte wollte man
zügig angehen welche aber darüber gibt's
Streit die Grünen wollen vor allem den
Zugverkehr fördern die FDP das Auto
konkret möchte Verkehrsminister Wissing
144 Projekte realisieren Beispiele und
zwar ein paar der laut Ministerium
dringlichen Vorhaben der Ausbau und wie
bei Hamburg Neubau von Autobahnen
teilsonnen bei Frankfurt Routen auf zehn
Spuren erweitert werden nötig weil der
Individualverkehr zunehmen so die FDP
die Grünen lehnen die Pläne ab sie
wollen dagegen weniger Autoverkehr mehr
Busse Bahnen Alternativen zum Auto
bessere Anbindung im öffentlichen nah
und Fernverkehr schnellere Taktung kurz
eine Verkehrswende für mehr Klima und
Umweltschutz
Bahn gegen Autobahn Schiene gegen Straße
grüne gegen FDP die Wege gehen in Sachen
Verkehr auseinander eine zügige Einigung
scheint schwierig
ja schwierige vielleicht eine Einigung
zu finden wir haben es gehört also
sprechen wir noch mal über diese zwei
Positionen Autobahnausbau sei wichtig um
den Wohlstand zu sichern sagte der
Verkehrsminister das ist ihnen ja auch
wichtig Frau Rittmann aber wie wollen
Sie das dann quasi sichern wenn sie
sagen Autobahnausbau mit uns das soll
nicht passieren
ne die Frage ist doch am Ende wozu baut
man die Autobahnen aus also wir haben in
Deutschland das mit beste Verkehrsnetz
auch an Straßen und da können die LKWs
drüber fahren die die Dinge von A nach B
transportieren müssen und die andere
große Frage die einfach immer vergessen
wird ist doch wie halten wir die
Klimaziele ein und sie Herr Killer sind
ja auch klimapolitische Sprecher ihre
Fraktion sie wissen dass das was gerade
passiert von Herrn Wissing nicht genug
ist und dass wir da 14 Mal schneller
werden müssen um das 20 30 Ziel
einzuhalten und wenn am Ende man es
runterrechnet auf wie viel CO2 wurde
imitiert progefahrenen Kilometer dann
schneidet das Auto langfristig einfach
am schlechtesten ab die wollen sie
schneller werden Herr Köhler
ich glaube vielleicht zu auch noch mal
zu dem Beitrag zurück kommt dann muss
man eine Sache auseinanderhalten die
Frage die ja diskutiert wird ist wie
schnell bauen wir Autobahn dass die
Frage der planungsbescheinigung das ist
der Streit die Diskussion und da geht es
ja auch nicht nur um die Autobahn
sondern da geht's auch darum wie schnell
bauen wir Bahnstrecken oder wie schnell
ersetzen wir Brücken wir brauchen Moment
15 Jahre um einen Ersatzbau Neubau von
der Brücke zu planen und zu Genehmigung
sind sie beim Klimaschutz das wäre meine
Frage
ganz kurz ich glaube die beiden Sachen
hängen ganz eng miteinander zusammen
weil
Klimaschutz bedeutet ja nicht wir müssen
an einer kleinen Stellschraube bewegen
wir müssen nur eine Sache verändern und
dann wird alles gut so das glaube ich
denken niemand und das kann ja auch
nicht das Ziel oder die Idee dahinter
sein sondern wir müssen alles
beschleunigen und wir müssen schneller
werden im Bau von erneuerbaren Energie
müssen schneller werden den Bau von
Bahnstrecken aber wir müssen eben auch
schneller werden im Bauch von Autobahn
und deswegen ist die
planungsbeschleunigung meiner Meinung
nach das falsche Thema wo man etwas
blockieren sollte jetzt im Moment wie
die Grünen gerade den autobahnenausbau
auf der anderen Seite ist aber natürlich
Klimaschutz enorm wichtig und deswegen
ist es auch aus unserer Sicht genau der
richtige Schritt das ist leider ein
bisschen untergegangen am Anfang des
Jahres aber auf europäischer Ebene haben
wir den europäischen Emissionshandel
jetzt erweitert auf die sektorenverkehr
und Wärme der gibt ein CO2 Limit vor
über dem hinaus nicht ausgeschlossen
werden darf und ich glaube der Zentrale
Ansatz von Klimapolitik sollte sein
möglichst viele Emissionen möglichst
schnell zu reduzieren und das
funktioniert eben am besten über
emissionshandelsysteme deswegen müssen
wir aus unserer Sicht dass sich der
Freien Demokraten genauso schnell wie
möglich in Deutschland ausweiten dieses
Cap also diese CO2 Limit das Verbot ist
Ausstoßes über dem was noch erlaubt ist
also was wir noch zur Verfügung haben
auch wirklich ernsthaft verbieten und
das was dann darunter liegt dass regeln
wir ja am sinnvollsten über den Markt
das funktioniert Bereich bereits im
missionshandel 1 also für Industrie und
Energie ganz wunderbare kapizide immer
ein die wir uns setzen deswegen wäre es
aus unserer Sicht klug das zu erweitern
das ist aber auch das ist nicht die
einzige Variante Volker Wissing hat
einen in ganz
weitreichenden Plan vorgelegt wie wir
die zum Beispiel die Lade Infrastruktur
für
E-Mobilität ausbauen und das ist
natürlich auch ein ganz ganz
wesentlicher Bestandteil und auch beim
ÖPNV sagen wir ja nicht ÖPNV ist des
Teufels den wollen wir nicht ausbauen
natürlich müssen natürlich müssen wir es
einfacher machen aber dass wir jetzt in
jedes Dorf
im ländlichen Raum die busdatum so
hochsetzen dass ÖPNV perfekt
funktioniert und das alle Menschen
einfach sagen sie können darauf
umsteigen ohne dass sie riesen Probleme
haben zur Arbeit zu kommen das wird
nicht in ein zwei Jahren funktionieren
das wird wahrscheinlich in zehn Jahren
funktionieren weil dazu brauchen sie
autonomes fahren dazu brauchen sie ganz
neue streckenkonzepte neue ÖPNV Konzepte
Verbindung von Verkehr und das muss in
ein integriertes Verkehrskonzept
eingebracht werden daran arbeiten wir
gerade deswegen sehe ich da kein Problem
und auch kein Widerspruch ich verstehe
noch nicht wie Sie mit dem Bau von neuen
Auto bei Emissionen senken wollen also
von Ausbau von erneuerbaren vom Ausbau
vom innen von der Infrastruktur von der
Bahn auf jeden Fall das brauchen wir
aber warum müssen wir neue Straßen bauen
wenn langfristig eigentlich klar ist um
die CO2-Emission im Verkehrssektor
runter zu bekommen müssen wir mehr Leute
in den öffentlichen Personen nachverkehr
kriegen und in den Fernverkehr und das
wird uns nicht helfen indem wir dann
neue Straßen bauen
gerne direkte Antwort Herr Köhler ja ist
es hier nicht langfristig klar dass wir
das tun müssen also dem würde ich
widersprechen die Frage ist doch nicht
ist individualer also müssen wir
Individualverkehr senken und das hilft
den Klimaschutz sondern die Frage ist
mit was fährt der Individualverkehr und
man kann natürlich sagen wir senken den
Individualverkehr komplett auf Null oder
auf möglichst wenig runter ich glaube
das hat ganz andere auch
kosteninvestitionsbedarfe ganz andere
Herausforderungen oder wir sagen wir
kriegen die bestehende Flotte also so
schnell wie möglich CO2 neutral und ich
glaube dass das der wesentliche Schritte
ist und da kann man zwei Konzepte die
kann man nebeneinander liegen beide
führen dazu dass wir Klimaschutz
umsetzen ich glaube sogar dass das
Konzept möglichst schnell einen CO2
neutralen Verkehr hinzukriegen über
E-Mobilität und ist der richtige Weg und
ist vor allen Dingen der Weg der
vielversprechend ist weil wir sind ja
nicht also wir sind ja nicht alleine wir
werden ja wir müssen in Europa
Klimaziele einhalten und haben wir jetzt
auch in Frankreich und Bulgarien den öpn
den Individualverkehr komplett
abschaffen würde ich nicht von ausgehen
das heißt Verkehr wird immer weiterhin
auch nötig sein auch übrigens
Warentransporte das heißt Autobahnen
brauchen wir das die Studie die Sie
gerade angesprochen haben zeigen das ja
auch dass der erwachsen wird der Verkehr
und deswegen ist es doch total sinnvoll
dafür zu sorgen so schnell wie möglich
und wir reden noch mal nicht über die
Frage welche Autobahn wir reden wir
ausbauen sondern in dieser Diskussion
innerhalb der Ampel geht es im Moment
nur und die Planung zu schneiden ich
glaube das sollte man auseinanderhalten
so der Verkehr der steigt die Frage ist
natürlich welche Schlüsse zieht man
drauf jetzt haben sie die Eve News wie
sie genannt werden schon zum zweiten mal
angesprochen deswegen möchte ich da
gerne kurz einhaken dann diskutieren wir
weiter denn über diese ifuels wird
kontrovers diskutiert wir haben einen
Beitrag vorbereitet schauen zusammen
rein Beitrag von Christiane hübscher
um e-fuse ist ein echter Kulturkampf
entbrannt die FDP streitet darum mit der
EU-Kommission will in letzter Sekunde
eine Ausnahme vom europaweiten
Verbrenner Verbot selbstverständlich
bleiben wir bei unserer Haltung wir sind
bereit den Kompromiss der Kommission zu
unterstützen wenn gleichzeitig die Frage
beantwortet ist wie Verbrennungsmotoren
nach 2035 zugelassen werden können wenn
sie nachweislich nur mit synthetischen
Kraftstoffen betankt werden können denn
klimaneutrale Mobilitätsangebote zu
verbieten macht nun wirklich keinen Sinn
das sind synthetische Kraftstoffe die
ganz ohne Rohöl hergestellt werden aus
möglichst grünem Strom und Wasser wird
Wasserstoff gewonnen dazu gibt man CO2
aus der Umwelt und fertig ist der Ersatz
Sprit der dann tatsächlich klimaneutral
ist
Nachteils sind längst nicht marktreif
teuer in der Herstellung und ihre
Energieeffizienz liegt nur bei ca 15% .
so kann ein Elektroauto mit der gleichen
Energiemenge bis zu fünfmal so weit
fahren
nutzbar wären eines Tages wohl für
Schiffe und Flugzeuge weil die nicht gut
elektrisch angetrieben werden können
aber efuse im großen Maßstab für PKW das
erscheint Experten unrealistisch die FDP
habe sich da verkämpft sagen die Grünen
ich habe den Eindruck dass das eher
ein Profilierungsversuch der FDP ist
allerdings auf Kosten von Arbeitsplätzen
Industrie und Klimaschutz für Dienstag
war eigentlich die finale Abstimmung der
EU-Staaten über das Verbrenner
ausgeplant jetzt ist es verschoben weil
auch Deutschland bremst
also das Verbrenner aus erstmal
verschoben in der Abstimmung Frau
Rittmann wir haben Kommentare bei uns im
Stream viele ich möchte einmal kurz
rausgreifen von quasi der schreibt bei
Youtube er oder sie natürlich ausbauen
wir wollen keinen Wettbewerbsnachteil
was ist denn ihre Antwort auf so eine
Sorge von Menschen die sagen sie wollen
keinen Wettbewerbsnachteil und eben auch
auf Menschen auf dem Land die eben auf
den Individualverkehr angewiesen sind
ich glaube das muss dann auf jeden Fall
voneinander trennen also einmal die
Frage wie transportieren wir waren durch
Deutschland der bleibt immer noch klar
dass super viele Straßen ja da sind wir
haben ganz viel Infrastruktur in
Deutschland und dann sind die auch die
Frage wie transportiert man waren kriegt
man sie auf die Schiene teilweise wo
kann man das Umlagern und dann gibt's
natürlich Anbindung das hat der Köder ja
angesprochen die müssen langfristig mit
dem Lastwagen abgedeckt bleiben aber ob
man dafür jetzt die Menge an neuen
Autobahnen bauen muss gerade wenn du
Individualverkehr weniger werden wird
wenn man die Klimaziele einhält und das
sagen alle Studien dann da geben sich
doch große Fragen die Frage wie bindet
man das Land an ist auf jeden Fall eine
große Frage es braucht sharing-angebote
ist wird da auch langfristig bis diese
mittelfristig noch Autos geben müssen
und die müssen dann aber eben aktiv
elektrifiziert sein das hat der Beitrag
ja auch gerade super erklärt dass wir
90% Prozess Verluste bei efuels haben
also das ist keine Technologie die jetzt
funktioniert aber die imakrise ist jetzt
da und die Emission müssen bis 20 30
runter damit die FDP ihr Klimaziele
einhält und da verstehe ich nicht wie
das Zusammenkommen soll die ifuel ist ja
sie haben es richtig zusammengefasst
auch gerade im Beitrag also die
Energieeffizienz wirklich nur gering
warum hält die FDP da so dran fest Herr
Köhler das macht ja so von außen
betrachtet erstmal wenig Sinn
ich glaube weil Klimaschutz ja eine
Aufgabe ist die besagt dass wir nicht
noch ein paar restimissionen einfach
weiterhin ausstoßen können sondern
Klimaschutz sagt immer und das sind die
Ziele die wir haben wir brauchen
Klimaneutralität wir müssen also 20:45
Uhr in Deutschland und 2050 spätestens
Klima hat eine Europa spätestens Klima
neutral sein aber das ist ja keine
rest-emission da muss ich mal ganz kurz
einhaken also von 15% über die
Energieeffizienz ist ein bisschen wenig
ganz kurz der der Gedanke der hinter ähm
im Moment haben wir ungefähr also wir
haben weltweit ungefähr 1,3 Milliarden
Fahrzeug wir brauchen so 15 bis 20 oder
25 Jahre bis wir eine bestandte
reduziert haben wenn wir also 2035 nur
noch Elektroautos zulassen würden und es
läuft alles ganz bombastisch nehmen wir
mal anders sind 15 Jahre dann können
hätten wir erst 20 50 wahrscheinlich
oder war vielleicht auch noch ein gutes
Stück später keine Verbrennungsmotoren
die gesamtemissionszeit ist aber
notwendig das ist die eine Sache die
eine Seite und wenn wir uns an die Welt
angucken und die Welt braucht
erneuerbare Energien und erneuerbare
Energien natürlich auch in Form von
Treibstoffen weil und das hat er Beitrag
ja auch gezeigt wir werden das auch für
Schiffsverkehr in den Flugverkehr für
uns ist aber bei der Diskussion und das
Verbrenner aus 2035 also das fossile
Verbrenner aus
für jedes gar nicht darum zu sagen wir
wollen die eine Technologie oder die
andere das war auch noch nie unser unser
Anspruch oder unser Ansagen wenn
E-Mobilität wirklich so effizient ist
und sich so viel besser durchsetzen und
so viel kosten gezielt dann wird sie
dies am Markt tun dafür muss ich aber
keine andere Technologie verbieten also
das ist die Debatte ist ein bisschen
schizophren entweder haben wir noch
hocheffiziente Technologie die günstiger
ist und besser ist dann setzt sich am
Markt durch dann brauche ich aber auch
keine keinen kein anderes Instrument und
kein wunderbar den die für zulassen oder
aber sie ist nicht so effizient dann ist
es natürlich eine Diskussion die offen
bleibt und zu der effizienzfrage
sprechen
wenn wir die Emissionen Verkehr runter
bekommen wollen dann müssen wir den
effizientesten Weg wählen
um
möglichst wenig Emission pro Kilometer
zu haben und wenn wir jetzt aber kein
Anreiz setzen sondern einfach beide
Technologien so um Luft drin Raum lassen
und dann aber neue Autobahn bauen um
Individualverkehr also auch Autos mit
auf die Straßen zu bringen dann fördern
die ineffiziente Technologie obwohl der
öffentliche personalverkehr viel
effizienter wäre um Emission einzusparen
wenn natürlich wenn man sich mit
Personen Kilometer teilt man weniger
Emission pro Kilometer hat
also das widerspricht sich nicht weil
sie ja auch mit E-Autos auf Autobahnen
fahren würden also wenn wir in der
Debatte um die Autos sind ja
ineffizienter als der öffentliche Person
ennahverkehr das effizienteste ist
eigentlich der der der Autobus aber auch
ein
auto-bus also einen flixbus zum Beispiel
aber einen Bus der auf dem Land mit
wenig Fahrgästen fährt ist natürlich
wesentlich ineffizienter als ein
vollgesetztes Auto also da kann man über
sharing sprechen und sonstige Fragen ich
würde gar nicht in die Frage so sehr
einstellen weil das ist ja dass wir
gerade diskutiert haben wollen wir Klima
neutralen Verkehr dann ist es egal mit
welcher Antriebstechnologie oder mit
welchem mit welchem Obst oder
Individualverkehr weil er da nur die
Frage entsteht womit wird das Auto
angekommen wenn wir aber sagen wir
wollen Autos insgesamt reduzieren dann
kann man das als diese total vertreten
da würde ich auch nicht nein sagen zu
ähm es ist nur nicht die These die wir
vertreten wir sagen Individualverkehr
ist völlig legitim der muss nur
klimaneutral werden und das kann er eben
über zwei Wege entweder übers oder über
Immobilität beide Wege sind für uns
total akzeptabel die Menschen wollen
dass man selber entscheiden können ich
habe Philosophie studiert ich habe einen
äh sehen sie dass sie damit ihre klimaz
ich kann doch gar nicht also ich kann
doch
entscheidend auf die Frage noch
Antworten Herr Köhler also Frau Rittmann
der hatte gerade noch eine Gegenfrage
gestellt sehen sie dass sie damit die
Klimaziele einhalten können die finden
glaube ich auch viele Userin User
spannend also jetzt gerade müssen wir im
Verkehrsbereich 14 Mal schneller werden
und das Programm was wir wissen
vorgelegt hat lässt gigantische Lücken
auch die Expertenrat der Bundesregierung
hat gesagt das passt einfach nicht
zusammen mit dem 20 30 Klimaziel der
Bundesregierung was ja auch immer noch
wenn man sich andere Studien anguckt zu
Debatte steht ob das für Pariser Klima
Abkommen reicht also die Frage wie
reduzieren wir die Missionen im Verkehr
bis 2030 was ist der exakte Plan die
konnte er wissen nicht beantworten und
da frage ich mich was sagen sie da ins
Kino politischer Sprecher zu auch in
ihrer Partei also da sind einfach die
Lücken doch riesig
nun Olaf NRW nicht vorwegzugreifen der
mittlerweile klimapolitischer Sprecher
ist ich bin allerdings auch für
Klimapolitik in der Partei als
stellvertreterinationsvorsitzender
zuständig
der das Instrument und das sinnvollste
und am besten funktionierendes
Instrument ist immer noch der
europäische missionshandel den haben wir
ja das habe ich gerade angesprochen
ausgeweitet und meiner Meinung nach ist
das Cap dass wir jetzt einziehen müssen
auch um die deutschen Klima zu Ziele
umzusetzen so schnell wie möglich
einzuziehen aus Sicht der Freien
Demokraten ist das auf der Königsweg
weil wir so steuern können wie wir
wirklich effizient umsetzen können sie
haben mir eben auch in der Diskussion zu
Klimazielen zum Verkehr zur Diskussion
oder
Immobilität gerade gesagt es gibt kein
anderes Argument das stimmt aber kein
anderes Instrument das stimmt aber nicht
weil das Instrument der europäische
missionshandel der über den CO2-Preis
und einen Cap dafür sorgt und
sicherstellt dass wir die Ziele
Einheiten das ist das Instrument das am
besten funktioniert hat das auch immer
wieder bewiesen hat das ist am besten
funktioniert und deswegen wäre es aus
unserer Sicht absolut klug und auch der
richtige Weg das jetzt so schnell wie
möglich auszuweiten ab 2027 ist es auf
europäischer Ebene geplant aber aus
meiner Sicht spricht auch nichts dagegen
dass sehr viel früher umzusetzen wir
könnten in Deutschland schon viel
schneller damit starten zu mal wer das
brennstoffemission handelsgesetz haben
da müssen wir allerdings auch noch mal
mit den Koalitionspartnern überlegen so
ich möchte jetzt gerne mal einen Haken
denn ich möchte sie gerne mal mehr
unsere Userinnen und User einbringen die
fleißig mit kommentieren und auch Fragen
stellen und haben wer ihnen recht geben
würde Herr Köhler in einem was ich
bislang jetzt so gehört habe wäre mit
Sicherheit User Userin red juris
schreibt bei Youtube ich will irgendwo
noch selber entscheiden dürfen ob ich
Auto oder Öffis fahre da geht's also um
die individuelle Entscheidung die so
wichtig ist die sie auch angesprochen
haben was immer wieder häufig kam und da
möchte ich gerne sie Frau Wittmann auch
dazu Fragen ist natürlich schon dass das
mit dem ÖPNV ja nicht ganz so einfach
ist wie man sich entschuldigung dass ich
meine Haare Mikrofon verfangen das ist
schwierig für die Zuschauer dann zu
hören jetzt ist besser also ÖPNV sie
haben dafür heute sind sie auf die
Straße gegangen für einen besseren
Ausbau von ÖPNV aber es gibt natürlich
massig Probleme die sind lang hier
schreibt z.B unser User Sven unter bei
Facebook Emissionshandel ist das eine
aber Förderung der beschwerlichen
Verwendung von klimaneutralen
Technologien auf der anderen Seite wenn
ich anschaue was eine Bahncard 100
kostet dann verstehe ich warum die die
es können und nicht auf dem Land wohnen
nicht umsteigen eine Meinung von Sven
Odenthal und jetzt eine Frage von Sniper
only der oder die schreibt bei Youtube
was sind denn die Pläne für das Land da
ist der ÖPNV Nation nicht existent und
mehr davon ist unglaublich teuer und
quasi nicht finanzierbar wie wollen wir
diese Leute denn erreichen deshalb noch
mal die Frage an Sie Frau wird man weil
ja auch häufiger der Vorwurf kommt die
Proteste in den Großstädten sind fern
von der Lebensrealität der Menschen in
auf dem Land im ländlichen Raum was ist
ihre Antwort darauf
ich verstehe dass Menschen nicht
umsteigen können also ich habe auch
keinen Bock morgens um sechs aufzustehen
um auf eine Bus zu warten der nicht
kommt aber du musst die Antwort darauf
doch sein wenn wir sagen wir wollen
innerhalb des Pariser Klimaabkommens
bleiben wir wollen Mobilität für alle
ermöglichen muss die Antwort doch sein
wir bauen den ÖPNV aus wie erweiten den
aus wie investieren in die Schiene also
das ist ja einfach kaputt gespart und
auch das ist ja eine Frage von Priorität
also was baut man aus wo investiert man
am Ende das Geld rein in den ÖPNV oder
in den Straßenausbau und kurzfristig
werden wir natürlich auch auf dem Land
weiter das Auto benutzen müssen und
mittelfristig muss das eben und
langfristig vielleicht teilweise auch
elektrisch bleiben da braucht es dann
eben diese sharing Angebote von denen
Herr Müller ja auch gesprochen hat so
und das ist eine Frage die sich also gar
nicht stellt aber eine gute ÖPNV sorgt
ja dafür dass er am Ende die Person gar
nicht darüber nachdenken muss den
öffentlichen Auto zu steigen so aber
solange wir irgendwie gar nicht
weiterkommen steigen die Menschen
natürlich nicht um die Lösung ist aber
ja nicht den ÖPNV da nicht auszubauen
und einfach weiter bei der Straße zu
bleiben und dann fliegt uns Klima um die
Ohren
das sagt Frau Rittmann von Fridays for
future und die Diskussion war spannend
sie war natürlich aber auch lang ich
denke mal wir könnten das gerne noch mal
wiederholen da sind noch einige Fragen
offen aber für heute für den Moment
möchte ich mich bedanken bei der
klimaaktivistin Annika Wittmann von
Fridays for future und bei dem
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
FDP-Fraktion bei Lukas Köhler danke für
die spannende Diskussion an sie beide
vielen Dank
wir haben uns nämlich noch eine
Gesprächspartnerin eingeladen jetzt in
dieser Sendung mit der wir jetzt
sprechen können über noch einige dieser
offenen Fragen und wir betrachten das
ganze jetzt mal ganz nüchtern auch
einfach von der wissenschaftlichen
Perspektive denn bei uns ist jetzt
Professor Dr Michael yipp sie ist am
Institut für Verkehrsforschung am
deutschen Zentrum für Luft und Raumfahrt
die sich ja auch mit Verkehr
beschäftigen das wusste ich so konkret
vorher auch nicht schön dass Sie bei uns
sind hallo Frau Dr jung
vielen Dank für die Einladung Frau Dr
sie haben gerade mit zugehört hitzige
Diskussionen die da stattgefunden hat
ist ja auch ganz klar bei natürlich auch
unterschiedlichen Standpunkten die es
gibt deswegen jetzt sehr spannend sie
mit ihrer Perspektive was sagen sie zu
der Aussage wir haben die Sendung damit
begonnen das Verkehrsministers das ist
eben dringend beschleunigten Ausbau vor
allem der Autobahn der Straße also für
das Auto braucht
30 Jahren ungefähr ja
okay
das Verkehrsministers ja ich hoffe das
jetzt die Technik funktioniert und sind
tatsächlich auch gut hören können
wirklich danke ja aber wenn man sich den
den Ausbau der Infrastruktur sowohl auf
der China einfach auf einer Straße
anguckt da muss man natürlich auch
schauen okay wie entwickelt sich denn
der Verkehr in den nächsten Jahren in
den nächsten Jahrzehnten und das ist so
dass im Güterverkehr ein deutliches
Wachstum zu erwarten ist in
Personenverkehr ist es nicht ganz so
extrem sondern sich die letzten 30 Jahre
mal anguckt dann war das ein guter
Verkehr tatsächlich ein Anstieg von über
70% und ja dreiviertel dieser Güter gibt
in Deutschland Produkte oder
transportiert werden werden eben über
die Straße konzentriert im
Personenverkehr ist der wachsen ungefähr
20% dafür werden aber über 80% dieser
Kilometerleistung über die Straße über
die motorisierten Individualverkehr
praktisch erledigt und nicht mehr diese
Prognosen anschaue dann kann die Straße
schon irgendwann weg werden wobei ich
auch dazu sagen sein muss dass die
Schiene auch zumindest die Schiene hat
ja den Silo Nachteil dass man nicht so
einfach ausreichen kann also wenn wir
jetzt mit einem LKW unterwegs sind und
zum Beispiel ja eine Autobahn gesperrt
ist oder ein eine Lücke entsteht oder
besteht auf der Autobahn lässt sich
praktisch über andere Straßen ausweichen
das ist auch nicht besonders
co2-freundlich funktioniert aber in der
Schiene ist es ein notruffaktor also
insofern sollte man definitiv auch
drüber nachdenken in der Schule aktiv zu
werden und da zum Beispiel auch wissen
zu können absolut dazu passt nämlich die
Frage von User Userin
quizmee man weiß nicht so genau wie man
es ausspricht er oder sie fragt wenn man
die Zahlen vergleicht wurde im Jahr 2022
74 km neue Schienen verlegt dem entgegen
stehen 10.000 km neue Straßen liegen
dann die Prioritäten bei der FDP nicht
falsch fragt sich der oder die Userin
ja da muss ich Ihnen als
Wissenschaftlerin jetzt sagen dass
unsere Aufgabe ist es letztendlich
Wissen zur Verfügung zu stellen die ein
die Entscheidung an sich trifft die
Politik die hat ja dafür auch die die
Legitimation was uns eben aufhält wenn
man auf diese Zahlen guckt ist das eben
häufig auch dieses Argument mit der
Wirtschaft und der der der Stärke der
Wirtschaft in Deutschland betrachtet
wird also ich höre häufig dass wenn die
Wirtschaft gestärkt werden muss eben
auch mehr Straße aufgebaut werden muss
da gibt es eine Beziehung zwischen
diesen beiden Faktoren ja das ist aber
nur bedingt eine kausale Beziehung also
andersrum formuliert wenn man jetzt mehr
Straßen baut oder auch mehr
Schienennetze baut heißt das nicht dass
dadurch die Wirtschaft versteckt wird
das ist eher andersrum also wenn es der
Wirtschaft gut geht werden auch mehr
Güter praktisch transportiert also das
ist biologische Kette wobei ich auch
dazu sagen muss der gibt's auch Faktoren
die diese Beziehung beeinflussen glaube
ich auch recht einfach
nachvollziehbar zum Beispiel anguckt
also sehr gut geht dann geht ja auch der
Wirtschaft besser das heißt aber nicht
dass dadurch dann mehr Güter
transportiert werden weil die Banken ja
nicht Güter herstellt die dann über die
Straßen produziert werden also da gibt
es durchaus Faktoren die diesen Effekt
jeweils am abschwächen
die ist zu krass die ist super einfach
tatsächlich dargestellt also ich habe ja
vorhin kurz erzählt dass in den letzten
30 Jahren der Anstieg des Güterverkehrs
deutlich gewachsen ist dieser Anstieg
hat mit Outsourcing zu tun das heißt das
produzierende Gewerbe hat immer durch
die Herstellung von von teilgütern
verlagert dadurch ist Verkehr entstanden
auf den Straßen wir sehen aber auch dass
dieser Bereich des outsourcen gibt eben
stagniert und damit ist dieser Effekt
des Outsourcing der durch eine gute
Wirtschaft entstanden ist zu mehr
Verkehr auch geführt hat der flacht ab
so dass wir da tatsächlich nicht mehr so
sehr davon ausgehen dass es
Verkehrssystem die Straße ein großes
darstellt ist zum Beispiel der
Fachkräftemangel deutlich stärker weil
die LKWs brauchen ja auch im Moment
zumindest noch Menschen die fahren
ja und jetzt gibt es ja natürlich diese
ganz krasse Forderungen die Verfügung
steht also oder ja die sehr eindeutige
Forderung die dagegen steht von Freddys
for future die also sagen Autobahn als
Lösungen sind nicht mehr oder als die
Lösungen sind nicht tragbar und deshalb
eben für diesen Stopp das Ausbaus
plädieren ich sehe gerade schon sie ja
sie schütteln mit dem Kopf ganz so
einfach ist es dann auch nicht ja das
ist leider auch eine häufige Antwort der
Wissenschaft die Welt ist nicht schwarz
weiß in den Kontext weil was auch ja
bekannt ist und was auch die Zahlen sehr
sehr deutlich sagen also wenn wenn der
Verkehr stockt wenn es da deutlich
nichts gibt auf der Straße dann führt
das auch zum erhöhten CO2 Bedarf
letztendlich also es hilft schon die
gebrochenes auch zu reduzieren und auch
zu schauen dass Staus reduziert werden
und dass der Verkehr insgesamt flüssiger
läuft und da auch das hilft dem Thema
und war wieso stehen wir denn jetzt
eigentlich da wo wir stehen also wer hat
da denn vielleicht auch was versäumt es
gibt hier einen Kommentar von Joanne 712
er oder sie schreibt auch oder fragt
sich was ist denn ihre Experten Meinung
zum sogenannten Deutschland Takt 2017 da
gab es nämlich eine Meldung das quasi
der Ausbau der Bahn oder so wie man sich
das vorgestellt hat wie die Bahn
eigentlich da stehen müsste dass ich das
um Jahrzehnte verzögert also wer hat da
wann wie wo was versäumt
also da ist tatsächlich ein Stück meine
traurige Statistik wenn ich jetzt mal in
die Vergangenheit schaue also wenn ich
die Klimaschutzziele und die auch
gesetzlich verankert sind analysiere
dann müssen wir bis 2030 den CO2 Ausstoß
halbieren den wir im Verkehr hatten also
von 1990 praktisch aufgerechnet wenn ich
jetzt am überlege wir haben das Jahr
2021 also seit 1990 sind einige Jahre
ins Land gegangen und die verbrauche die
CO2 Verbraucher sind fast konstant also
das ist eine ziemliche Linie praktische
Emission die wir im Straßenverkehr dort
beobachten bis 20 30 sind noch sieben
Jahre Zeit
und der die Abbruchkante die wir
praktisch brauchen um diese
Klimaschutzziele für 20 30 zu erreichen
die wird halt immer immer schärfer die
kriegt immer stärker und das macht auch
immer schwieriger diese Ziele noch zu
erreichen und wenn ich dann noch mal
weitergehen dann bin ich bei 20:45 Uhr
da wollen wir in Deutschland immer
neutral sein
und da hilft tatsächlich sich einfach
mal anzuschauen okay wie entscheiden
denn Menschen wie sie eigentlich
unterwegs sind und da gibt's die
klassischen Kriterien am Zeitbedarf ist
ein Faktor Geld ist ein anderer Faktoren
und wenn ich mir jetzt alleine mal
anschaue wie in Deutschland die
Pendelzeiten so durchschnittlich sind
dann stellt man eben fest dass ein
Mensch dreimal so lange braucht
durchschnittlich bis er von seiner
Wohnung oder von unserem Haus
zu seinem Arbeitskorb braucht wenn Sie
den das Auto nimmt im Vergleich zum
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr und
Faktor 3 ist schon Wort also wieder
zurück
und dann ist es durchaus beim Großteil
der Menschen nachvollziehbar dass sie
eben aufs Auto gehen wenn sie dann ein
Auto zur Verfügung haben heißt aber
umgekehrt auch wenn ja an diesem
Entscheidungsmechanismen bei Menschen
etwas verändern wollen und auch müssen
wenn ich mir irgendwie gesetzlichen
Vorgaben anschauen dann ist es wichtig
den ÖPNV so aufzubauen dass er ja
flächendeckend fährt oder die
zugangszeiten zu dem ÖPNV kürzer werden
und auf die Reisezeiten
und da ist der Deutschland hat bis 20 70
schon etwas später also die
Klimaschutzziel
und dann noch die Frage die passt auch
im weitesten Sinne dazu von Benny the
Blessed er fragt sich warum brauchen wir
neue Autobahn überhaupt also die Frage
zieht ein bisschen darauf ab haben wir
nicht aktuell schon alles vorhanden was
es zu haben gilt und zwar fragt er oder
sie sich reparieren vorhandener
Autobahnen ja Richtung von mehr
E-Tankstellen auch aber neue Straßen wir
können doch jetzt schon überall hin mit
dem Auto oder nicht würden sie auch
sagen also eigentlich ist die
Infrastruktur da sie die vorhanden ist
nur zu schlecht ausgebaut
in Deutschland noch ein paar Lücken das
mag ein Überraschung wenn man auf die
Landkarte guckt aber es gibt noch Ecken
wo klar ist da geht der Güterverkehr
durch
und da gibt's eben auch tatsächlich noch
keine Autofahren und ähm da würde ich
auch wieder auf die Flüssigkeit des
Verkehrs noch mal achten also ein
flüssiger Verkehr auch auf der Straße
ist einer der weniger CO2 produziert
wenn dieser Verkehr dann auch die
Bundesstraße
Landstraßen umgeleitet wird dann fließt
der deutlich weniger flüssig und dann
habe ich auch wieder ein erhöhten
CO2-Ausstoß also es kann vor dem
Hintergrund schon sinnvoll sein
gewisse Lücken in diesem Netz auch zu
füllen und da auch Straßen auszubauen
wichtig ist allerdings dass man sich
auch da immer genau anguckt was
produziert das denn also kann ich damit
dann wirklich CO2 sparen oder für das
dann dazu dass ich
Verlagerungseffekte jetzt habe von China
oder von den Wasserwegen auf die Straße
und falls das der Fall ist dann habe ich
natürlich dann wieder eine schlechtere
Klima Bilanz weil naja es gibt natürlich
keine klimafreundlicheren Verkehrsmittel
als ähm ja mit dem Zug oder auf dem
Schiff unterwegs
vielleicht ganz konkret zum Schluss wie
könnte man denn ihrer Meinung nach
überhaupt die Menschen
konstruktiv oder irgendwie motivieren
jemals vom Auto wegzukommen wenn die
Anreize aufs Auto umzusteigen wie z.B
der der Komfort der so hoch ist die die
Geschwindigkeit die die Zeit die man
einfach einspart wenn das im Moment noch
so so viel mehr ausmacht
abgewogene Mix an Maßnahmen also wir
brauchen die wir schon jetzt gesprochen
haben tatsächlich einen Ausbau des
Angebots der ÖPNV muss flächendeckend
sein er muss auch zeitlich schneller
stattfinden also in Deutschland Thematik
was aber auch wichtig ist ist ein Stück
weit auch das Auto unkomfortabler zu
machen und da vielleicht auch
insbesondere in den Städten zu handeln
und sowas wie Management einzuführen
kurze Wege einzuführen und zu sagen okay
ich kann innerhalb meines Umkreises
indem ich lebe innerhalb von 15 Minuten
alles erreichen was ich für meinen
alltägliches Leben eben brauche so dass
ich nicht auf den Auto angewiesen bin um
erst in die Hand Gebiete der Stadt
praktisch zu fahren und dort alles
erledigen kann sondern wirklich kurze
Wege
schöne Wege auch das ist noch mal ganz
wichtiger Faktor kurze Distanz wir
brauchen saubere Verkehrsmittel die
möglichst ja gut angetrieben werden
elektrisch angetrieben werden
Elektromobilität letztendlich
auch komplett auf dem individuellen
können
[Musik]
sagt verkehrsforscherin Professor Dr
Michael yipp schön dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren vielen Dank für die
Einschätzung
und danke auch an euch das war eine
längere Sendung heute ein wenig ich
glaube auch ehrlicherweise nicht die
letzte zu dem Thema wie wir gehört und
gelernt haben spannende Diskussionen und
noch mal spannende Expertin Einschätzung
ich habe in den Kommentaren irgendwo mir
notiert dass ein User eine Userin
geschrieben hat warum denn nicht beides
wir brauchen ÖPNV und Autobahnen mehr
Autobahn weniger Stau also jemand der
für die goldene Mitte sich ausspricht
wir werden sehen wie das Ganze
weitergeht bleiben für euch dran jetzt
erstmal schönes Wochenende und bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss